Speaking of psychology is taking a Thanksgiving break this week, so we're rerunning an episode from our archives. Back in 2021, at the beginning of the holiday shopping season, I talked to University of Michigan professor Scott Rick about how emotions guide our shopping behavior and why Black Friday sales are so irresistible. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives, and we'll be back with a new episode next week. Does shopping bring you joy? Or do you feel a bit of pain or regret every time you have to make a purchase. Many of us will be shopping for gifts in the coming weeks, whether we enjoy it or not. So today we're going to talk about the psychology of shopping. How do our emotions drive our buying behaviors? Why do some people spend money so easily,
Speaking of psychology is taking a Thanksgiving break this week, so we're rerunning an episode from our archives. Back in 2021, at the beginning of the holiday shopping season, I talked to University of Michigan professor Scott Rick about how emotions guide our shopping behavior and why Black Friday sales are so irresistible. We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives, and we'll be back with a new episode next week. Does shopping bring you joy? Or do you feel a bit of pain or regret every time you have to make a purchase. Many of us will be shopping for gifts in the coming weeks, whether we enjoy it or not. So today we're going to talk about the psychology of shopping. How do our emotions drive our buying behaviors? Why do some people spend money so easily,|||《Speaking of Psychology》播客本周迎来感恩节假期，因此我们重播了一期往期节目。早在 2021 年假日购物季开始时，我采访了密歇根大学教授斯科特·里克（Scott Rick），探讨了情绪如何引导我们的购物行为，以及为什么黑色星期五的促销如此令人无法抗拒。希望大家喜欢这期往期节目，我们下周将推出新节目。购物会给你带来快乐吗？还是每次购物时，你都会感到一丝痛苦或后悔？在接下来的几周里，无论我们是否喜欢，许多人都将采购礼物。因此，今天我们将探讨购物心理学。我们的情绪是如何驱动购买行为的？为什么有些人花钱如此痛快，
even when they shouldn't, while others find it difficult to splurge even when they can afford it? Does buying a gift feel the same as buying something for yourself? Is retail therapy a real thing? Can shopping boost your mood? And why are Black Friday sales so irresistible? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Scott Rick, an associate professor of marketing at the University of Michigan's
even when they shouldn't, while others find it difficult to splurge even when they can afford it? Does buying a gift feel the same as buying something for yourself? Is retail therapy a real thing? Can shopping boost your mood? And why are Black Friday sales so irresistible? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Scott Rick, an associate professor of marketing at the University of Michigan's|||甚至在不该花钱的时候也是如此，而另一些人即使负担得起，也很难大手大脚地花钱？买礼物和给自己买东西的感觉一样吗？“零售疗法”真的存在吗？购物能改善你的情绪吗？为什么黑色星期五的大促销如此势不可挡？欢迎收听《Speaking of Psychology》，这是美国心理学协会（APA）的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是斯科特·里克博士（Dr. Scott Rick），他是密歇根大学
Ross School of Business. His research focuses on understanding the emotional causes and consequences. of consumer financial decision-making, with a particular interest in the behavior of tightwads and spendthrifts, people who chronically spend more or less money than they want to, or perhaps should. The goal of his work is to understand
Ross School of Business. His research focuses on understanding the emotional causes and consequences. of consumer financial decision-making, with a particular interest in the behavior of tightwads and spendthrifts, people who chronically spend more or less money than they want to, or perhaps should. The goal of his work is to understand|||罗斯商学院的市场营销学副教授。他的研究重点是理解消费者财务决策的情绪起因与结果，尤其对吝啬鬼（tightwads）和挥霍者（spendthrifts）的行为感兴趣——也就是那些长期花费比自己预期（或应该花费的）更多或更少钱的人。他的工作目标是理解
why consumers behave the way they do and to develop interventions to improve their decision-making and well-being. He has published in journals dedicated to marketing, psychology, management, neuroscience, and economics. And his research has been covered by many media outlets, including the New York Times,
why consumers behave the way they do and to develop interventions to improve their decision-making and well-being. He has published in journals dedicated to marketing, psychology, management, neuroscience, and economics. And his research has been covered by many media outlets, including the New York Times,|||消费者为什么会做出这样的行为，并开发出相应的干预措施，以改善他们的决策和幸福感。他曾在专注于市场营销、心理学、管理学、神经科学和经济学的学术期刊上发表过多篇文章。他的研究也受到了许多媒体的报道，包括《纽约时报》、
Times, The Wall Street Journal, The Washington Post, and NPR. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Rick. Thank you so much for having me. Really happy to be here. One of the things you're known for is developing the tightwad spendthrift scale. So let's start there. We all know that some people spend money more easily than others, but you found there are real brain and behavioral differences between tightwads and spendthrifts and that they're related to an emotional experience called the pain of paying. Can you tell us more about that research. Yeah. So that started just based on conversations. I'm personally a spendthrift, raised by spendthrifts. And my advisor back in grad school, George Lowenstein, was a tightwad.
Times, The Wall Street Journal, The Washington Post, and NPR. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Rick. Thank you so much for having me. Really happy to be here. One of the things you're known for is developing the tightwad spendthrift scale. So let's start there. We all know that some people spend money more easily than others, but you found there are real brain and behavioral differences between tightwads and spendthrifts and that they're related to an emotional experience called the pain of paying. Can you tell us more about that research. Yeah. So that started just based on conversations. I'm personally a spendthrift, raised by spendthrifts. And my advisor back in grad school, George Lowenstein, was a tightwad.|||《华尔街日报》、《华盛顿邮报》和美国全国公共广播电台（NPR）等。非常感谢您能作客我们的节目，里克博士。非常感谢邀请我来。很高兴能来到这里。您广为人知的一项成就是开发了“吝啬鬼-挥霍者量表”（tightwad spendthrift scale）。那我们就从这里开始吧。我们都知道有些人比其他人花钱更痛快，但您发现吝啬鬼和挥霍者之间存在真实的脑部和行为差异，并且这与一种被称为“付款痛苦”（pain of paying）的情绪体验有关。您能多给我们讲讲这项研究吗？好的。这其实是从一些交谈开始的。我本人就是一个挥霍者，而且是在挥霍者家庭中长大的。我读研究生时的导师乔治·洛ewenstein（George Loewenstein）则是个吝啬鬼。
And I was finding a lot of people in my life seemed to be tightwads. They seem to have a lot of distress when thinking about spending money. And that was kind of a strange thing to me that, if anything, my distress came afterwards once I saw like the credit card bill or things. like that. So yeah, we we did some stuff like have people shop while having their brain scan with functional MRI. And we found some evidence consistent with this idea of a pain of pain that people use feelings of distress as kind of the brakes on the car. So like the more kind of anxious or uncomfortable I am when thinking about spending the money, the less likely I am to do it. Now, some people have too much of that. That's the tight ones. And that could come from
And I was finding a lot of people in my life seemed to be tightwads. They seem to have a lot of distress when thinking about spending money. And that was kind of a strange thing to me that, if anything, my distress came afterwards once I saw like the credit card bill or things. like that. So yeah, we we did some stuff like have people shop while having their brain scan with functional MRI. And we found some evidence consistent with this idea of a pain of pain that people use feelings of distress as kind of the brakes on the car. So like the more kind of anxious or uncomfortable I am when thinking about spending the money, the less likely I am to do it. Now, some people have too much of that. That's the tight ones. And that could come from|||我发现我生活中的许多人似乎都是吝啬鬼。他们在考虑花钱时似乎会感到极大的痛苦。这对我来说有点奇怪，因为如果说我有什么痛苦的话，那也是在看到信用卡账单或类似的东西之后才产生的。所以，我们做了一些实验，比如让人们在接受功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）扫描大脑的同时进行购物。我们发现了一些证据，与“付款痛苦”这一观点相吻合：人们将痛苦的感觉当作汽车的刹车。也就是说，当我想到花钱时，我越感到焦虑或不舒服，我就越不可能去花钱。现在，有些人这种痛苦感过头了，这就是吝啬鬼。而这可能源于
lots of places, including maybe there was some financial distress earlier in life that they just can't shake later when their objective financial situation improves. And then there are those of us like spendthrifts who just don't have enough of it. We don't think about spending as mathematically. We're more focused on the present than the future. So there are these kind of big differences. And we developed a scale, a tight-wad spend-thrift scale, to measure this, and figure out what it's different from.
lots of places, including maybe there was some financial distress earlier in life that they just can't shake later when their objective financial situation improves. And then there are those of us like spendthrifts who just don't have enough of it. We don't think about spending as mathematically. We're more focused on the present than the future. So there are these kind of big differences. And we developed a scale, a tight-wad spend-thrift scale, to measure this, and figure out what it's different from.|||很多因素，包括可能早年生活中有过一些财务困境，以至于后来客观财务状况改善时，他们仍然无法摆脱这种阴影。然后就是像我们这样的挥霍者，我们没有足够的这种“痛苦感”。我们在花钱时不会从数学角度去细算。我们更关注当下，而不是未来。因此，这里面存在着很大的差异。我们开发了一个量表，即“吝啬鬼-挥霍者量表”，来衡量这一点，并弄清楚它与其他特质的区别。
For example, being a tightwad is very different than being a frugal person. A frugal person, they love to save, and it's fun, and they enjoy it, and they're happy. A tight wand just really dislikes spending, and they're not so happy, and they, you know, they're not buying the gifts that they should for their partner, and they're not going on the vacations they should, and they're walking around in shoes that hurt, even though they have the money to buy better shoes. And, you know, spendthrifts aren't on cloud nine either. They're often in debt and kind of kicking themselves for spending too much. We do find there's this middle ground of unconflicted consumers who kind of have a reasonable
For example, being a tightwad is very different than being a frugal person. A frugal person, they love to save, and it's fun, and they enjoy it, and they're happy. A tight wand just really dislikes spending, and they're not so happy, and they, you know, they're not buying the gifts that they should for their partner, and they're not going on the vacations they should, and they're walking around in shoes that hurt, even though they have the money to buy better shoes. And, you know, spendthrifts aren't on cloud nine either. They're often in debt and kind of kicking themselves for spending too much. We do find there's this middle ground of unconflicted consumers who kind of have a reasonable|||例如，成为一个吝啬鬼与成为一个节俭的人有很大不同。节俭的人喜欢储蓄，这很有趣，他们享受其中并且感到快乐。而吝啬鬼则是真的讨厌花钱，他们并不那么快乐，而且你会发现，他们不给伴侣买该买的礼物，不去该去的度假，穿着磨脚的鞋子走来走去，尽管他们有钱买更好的鞋子。而且，你知道，挥霍者也并非处于极度快乐之中。他们经常负债累累，并为自己花钱太多而懊恼不已。我们确实发现，中间存在一个“无纠结消费者”（unconflicted consumers）的地带，他们对花钱持有理性的态度，
amount of pain when thinking about spending and they tend to be happiest. So are most of us somewhere in that middle ground then where we're neither a tightwad nor a spendthrift? Yeah, it depends on where you look. But around 50 to 60 percent of the people we sample are in that big middle ground. of the unconflicted consumer. And then it's about equally shared on the extremes. And it sounds like tightwads aren't really getting any pleasure out of, you know, accumulating their money, right?
amount of pain when thinking about spending and they tend to be happiest. So are most of us somewhere in that middle ground then where we're neither a tightwad nor a spendthrift? Yeah, it depends on where you look. But around 50 to 60 percent of the people we sample are in that big middle ground. of the unconflicted consumer. And then it's about equally shared on the extremes. And it sounds like tightwads aren't really getting any pleasure out of, you know, accumulating their money, right?|||在想到花钱时会感到适度的“痛苦”，并且他们往往是最快乐的。那么我们大多数人是否都处于中间地带，既不是吝啬鬼也不是挥霍者呢？是的，这取决于你观察的群体。但在我们抽样的人群中，大约 50% 到 60% 的人属于无纠结消费者的这个广阔中间地带。两端的比例则大致均等。听起来吝啬鬼并没有从积累金钱中获得任何真正的快乐，对吧？
I mean, they just have so much pain spending it. So that's the difference? Yeah, it's kind of anxiety maintenance, just a way to kind of calm the fears of going into bankruptcy. And when you listen to a lot of them kind of talk about their feelings and their thoughts, a lot of them do have memories of real distress in the past. And it's just hard to shake it once things get better. This reaction, these feelings are cultivated over time. And it's hard to switch it off, you know, like a light switch.
I mean, they just have so much pain spending it. So that's the difference? Yeah, it's kind of anxiety maintenance, just a way to kind of calm the fears of going into bankruptcy. And when you listen to a lot of them kind of talk about their feelings and their thoughts, a lot of them do have memories of real distress in the past. And it's just hard to shake it once things get better. This reaction, these feelings are cultivated over time. And it's hard to switch it off, you know, like a light switch.|||我的意思是，他们在花钱时会感到巨大的痛苦。这就是区别吗？是的，这有点像在维持一种焦虑，只是一种平息破产恐惧的方法。当你听许多人谈论他们的感受和想法时，你会发现他们中的许多人确实有过去真正痛苦的记忆。一旦情况变好，这种记忆也很难抹去。这种反应、这些感受是随着时间慢慢培养出来的。而且很难像电灯开关那样说关就关。
So I think for them, it kind of helps to manage the distress kind of holding onto money. Are spending habits related to other aspects of people's personalities, such as overall conscientiousness or extroversion? Or is the tightwads band thrift trait just its own thing? Yeah, no, it's related to things. So tightwads are more guilt-prone. They're a little more conscientious. It's not kind of just conscientiousness.
So I think for them, it kind of helps to manage the distress kind of holding onto money. Are spending habits related to other aspects of people's personalities, such as overall conscientiousness or extroversion? Or is the tightwads band thrift trait just its own thing? Yeah, no, it's related to things. So tightwads are more guilt-prone. They're a little more conscientious. It's not kind of just conscientiousness.|||所以我觉得对他们来说，把钱抓在手里有助于管理这种痛苦。消费习惯是否与人们性格的其他方面有关，比如整体的尽责性或外向性？还是说“吝啬鬼-挥霍者”这一特质是独立存在的？是的，它与其他特质息息相关。吝啬鬼更容易产生负罪感。他们更具有责任心。但这不仅仅是一般的责任心。
They're not necessarily flossing more, showing up to meetings on time more often. But there's some relation there. Yeah, and they tend to be a little more mathematical in their thinking. They can't shake the idea of opportunity costs. What am I giving up later? They, you know, they really do interpret a price tag in terms of what I'm foregoing. And, you know, I think they almost kind of blow that up a little bit.
They're not necessarily flossing more, showing up to meetings on time more often. But there's some relation there. Yeah, and they tend to be a little more mathematical in their thinking. They can't shake the idea of opportunity costs. What am I giving up later? They, you know, they really do interpret a price tag in terms of what I'm foregoing. And, you know, I think they almost kind of blow that up a little bit.|||他们不一定会更勤于用牙线清洁牙齿，也不一定会更经常按时开会。但两者之间确实存在某种联系。是的，他们的思维往往更偏向数学化。他们无法摆脱机会成本的概念。我以后会放弃什么？他们真的会根据自己放弃了什么来解读价签。而且，我觉得他们几乎把这一点稍微放大了一点。
Like, I'm foregoing, like, so much by spending now. So, yeah, you can see, like, differences in their college majors. There are some gender differences, too. Women are a little more likely to be spendthrifts than men are. But it's not just that. It's a small relationship, but it's there. You mentioned college majors. How does that play?
Like, I'm foregoing, like, so much by spending now. So, yeah, you can see, like, differences in their college majors. There are some gender differences, too. Women are a little more likely to be spendthrifts than men are. But it's not just that. It's a small relationship, but it's there. You mentioned college majors. How does that play?|||比如，我现在花钱等于放弃了巨多的东西。所以，你可以看到他们在大学专业上的差异。这里也存在一些性别差异。女性成为挥霍者的可能性比男性略高一些。但不仅仅是这样。虽然这种关联较弱，但它确实存在。你提到了大学专业。这在其中起到了什么作用？
So on the tightwad side, you tend to see more kind of engineering, mathematics, whereas on the spendthrift side, you tend to see more social work or social science. But you might be thinking like, oh, well, how does gender relate to this? We even find that within gender, you see these major differences. So women who are tightwads are more likely to have majored in engineering and math and women who are spent thrifts are more likely to major in social work and things like that. And so that's true for men as well. And so, yeah, there is definitely a different thinking style. And there's a lot of people who study emotion who say that there's no emotion without cognition. It's all kind of connected.
So on the tightwad side, you tend to see more kind of engineering, mathematics, whereas on the spendthrift side, you tend to see more social work or social science. But you might be thinking like, oh, well, how does gender relate to this? We even find that within gender, you see these major differences. So women who are tightwads are more likely to have majored in engineering and math and women who are spent thrifts are more likely to major in social work and things like that. And so that's true for men as well. And so, yeah, there is definitely a different thinking style. And there's a lot of people who study emotion who say that there's no emotion without cognition. It's all kind of connected.|||在吝啬鬼这一端，你会看到更多工程学、数学背景的人；而在挥霍者这一端，你会看到更多社会工作或社会科学背景的人。但你可能会想：“哦，那性别又是如何与这产生联系的呢？”我们甚至发现，在同一种性别内部，也能看到这些专业上的巨大差异。因此，身为吝啬鬼的女性更有可能主修工程和数学，而身为挥霍者的女性则更有可能主修社会工作之类的专业。男性也是如此。所以，这里的确存在不同的思维风格。许多研究情绪的人都说过，没有认知就没有情绪。这一切都是息息相关的。
And I think the thoughts and the feelings kind of, especially for tightwads, they kind of build on each other. Kind of the distress brings to mind thoughts of what I'm giving up later, which makes you more distressed and it's a cycle. So one thing people may be curious about is where these traits. come from and how early they develop. And I know you've found evidence of them even in very young children. Can you explain that? So we have developed a scale, a spin thrift type one scale for kids age five to ten. And, you know, it's a very simplified thing, kind of which cartoon character has feelings towards money that match what you have. And, you know, even there we get kind of a similar looking distribution of scores as we see among adults, kind of a similar amount in the middle
And I think the thoughts and the feelings kind of, especially for tightwads, they kind of build on each other. Kind of the distress brings to mind thoughts of what I'm giving up later, which makes you more distressed and it's a cycle. So one thing people may be curious about is where these traits. come from and how early they develop. And I know you've found evidence of them even in very young children. Can you explain that? So we have developed a scale, a spin thrift type one scale for kids age five to ten. And, you... know, it's a very simplified thing, kind of which cartoon character has feelings towards money that match what you have. And, you know, even there we get kind of a similar looking distribution of scores as we see among adults, kind of a similar amount in the middle|||我认为思想和情感——尤其是对吝啬鬼而言——它们会相互交织、层层叠加。痛苦感让人联想到以后会放弃什么，这会让你感到更加痛苦，从而形成一个恶性循环。因此，人们可能会好奇的一个问题是，这些特质从何而来，又是从多大年纪开始形成的。据我所知，您甚至在很小的儿童身上也发现了这些特质的证据。您能解释一下吗？我们开发了一个针对5到10岁儿童的挥霍者-吝啬鬼量表。这是一个非常简化的版本，类似于“哪个卡通人物对待金钱的感受与你最相似”。即便是在这个年龄段，我们也得到了与成年人相似的分数分布，中间人数所占比例相仿，
and then you're two extremes. Yeah, so we're looking into how that might transfer from parents to kids through conversation. So we bring these parent-child diads into the lab and have them talk through money situations. And you do see some kind of telltale signs like a spendthrift parent might be the kid might want to save and the spendthrift parent is like, well, are you sure? Like, there's some cool stuff here. I can definitely relate to that. But again, you know, a lot of it does seem to date back, at least among adults, to these really formative times in their life when things were really good or really bad and they just can't get past it once things change later. You know, it's been called sometimes a post-brokness stress disorder, like, you know, this idea that, you know, once broke and always broke in terms of your feelings, no matter what you're actually.
and then you're two extremes. Yeah, so we're looking into how that might transfer from parents to kids through conversation. So we bring these parent-child diads into the lab and have them talk through money situations. And you do see some kind of telltale signs like a spendthrift parent might be the kid might want to save and the spendthrift parent is like, well, are you sure? Like, there's some cool stuff here. I can definitely relate to that. But again, you know, a lot of it does seem to date back, at least among adults, to these really formative times in their life when things were really good or really bad and they just can't get past it once things change later. You know, it's been called sometimes a post-brokness stress disorder, like, you know, this idea that, you know, once broke and always broke in terms of your feelings, no matter what you're actually.|||两端则是两个极端。是的，我们正在研究这通过对话是如何从父母传递给孩子的。我们将这些亲子组合带进实验室，让他们讨论金钱相关的情境。你会发现一些明显的迹象，比如挥霍者父母的孩子可能想要存钱，而身为挥霍者的父母则会说：“嗯，你确定吗？这里有很多好玩的东西呢。”我绝对能对号入座。但话又说回来，许多情况——至少对成年人来说——似乎可以追溯到他们生命中那些真正具有塑造性的时期，那时生活要么极好，要么极糟，以至于后来情况发生变化时，他们也无法释怀。你知道，这有时被称为“创伤后穷困应激障碍”，也就是这种观念：一旦经历过贫穷，你的内心情感就永远处于贫穷状态，无论你实际的
bank account looks like now. It's there from an early age. I think part of it is kind of the internal wiring, kind of what your guilt-proneness, things like that, what you're born with, what your parents instill, and then kind of just your financial reality as a kid. It calls to mind, though, the marshmallow test with Walter Mitchell and kids who can delay gratification. Is that part of what's going on here as well? I think it is part of that, for sure. And tightwads are certainly better at that kind of thing. But we do find it's not kind of a general patience that tightweds aren't necessarily patient in a lot of other domains. It really does seem to be more specific to kind of how they think about parting with money.
bank account looks like now. It's there from an early age. I think part of it is kind of the internal wiring, kind of what your guilt-proneness, things like that, what you're born with, what your parents instill, and then kind of just your financial reality as a kid. It calls to mind, though, the marshmallow test with Walter Mitchell and kids who can delay gratification. Is that part of what's going on here as well? I think it is part of that, for sure. And tightwads are certainly better at that kind of thing. But we do find it's not kind of a general patience that tightweds aren't necessarily patient in a lot of other domains. It really does seem to be more specific to kind of how they think about parting with money.|||银行账户现在看起来如何。它从很小的时候就存在了。我认为部分原因在于内部的神经连线，比如你容易产生负罪感的倾向等天生带有的东西，以及父母灌输给你的观念，还有你小时候的真实财务状况。这让人想起沃尔特·米歇尔（Walter Mischel）的“棉花糖实验”，以及那些能够延迟满足的孩子。这也是其中一部分原因吗？我认为这确实是其中一部分。吝啬鬼显然更擅长这种延迟满足。但我们也发现，这并不是一种普遍的耐心，吝啬鬼在许多其他领域并不一定有耐心。它似乎更具体地体现在他们如何看待与金钱分离这件事上。
But, you know, if I had to, if I was forced to kind of bet on who's better able to wait for the second marshmallow, it would be the tightwad child, certainly. Yes. So you've looked at how money and spending habits figure in relationships, romantic relationships. And you've found that people actually tend to partner up with their opposite. The tightwads often marry spendthrifts and vice versa. Why does that happen and how does it work out for these couples? So there's a real clear pattern that you see in like sociology research of these patterns of fatal attraction, that if there's something you don't like about yourself and then you see it in someone else, that that tends to be kind of a real turnoff. It kind of repels you. It's this thing
But, you know, if I had to, if I was forced to kind of bet on who's better able to wait for the second marshmallow, it would be the tightwad child, certainly. Yes. So you've looked at how money and spending habits figure in relationships, romantic relationships. And you've found that people actually tend to partner up with their opposite. The tightwads often marry spendthrifts and vice versa. Why does that happen and how does it work out for these couples? So there's a real clear pattern that you see in like sociology research of these patterns of fatal attraction, that if there's something you don't like about yourself and then you see it in someone else, that that tends to be kind of a real turnoff. It kind of repels you. It's this thing|||不过，如果要我——如果我被迫下注谁更能忍耐以等待第二颗棉花糖，那肯定会是吝啬鬼小孩。是的。因此，您研究了金钱和消费习惯在人际关系尤其是浪漫关系中扮演的角色。您发现人们实际上倾向于与自己性格相反的人结为伴侣。吝啬鬼经常与挥霍者结婚，反之亦然。为什么会这样？这些伴侣最后的相处情况如何？在社会学研究中，你可以看到一种非常清晰的“致命吸引力”模式：如果你身上有什么不喜欢的地方，然后你在别人身上看到了这一点，这往往会让你非常反感。它会产生排斥感。这就是那种
that I'm self-conscious about and then I see someone else and it's just, ugh, it's enough when it's just me. I can't have a second version of that in the house. And so, you know, at first, it's really fun and exciting to find someone who doesn't have that issue that you dislike. And we do find that tight ones and spendthrifts don't like being tight ones and spin thrift thrifts. They're conflicted. That's why we call the people in the middle unconflicted. And so they tend to pair up more often than you would expect, more often than kind of a tightwad, tightwad couple or a spendthrift spendthrift couple. And so that's fun at first.
that I'm self-conscious about and then I see someone else and it's just, ugh, it's enough when it's just me. I can't have a second version of that in the house. And so, you know, at first, it's really fun and exciting to find someone who doesn't have that issue that you dislike. And we do find that tight ones and spendthrifts don't like being tight ones and spin thrift thrifts. They're conflicted. That's why we call the people in the middle unconflicted. And so they tend to pair up more often than you would expect, more often than kind of a tightwad, tightwad couple or a spendthrift spendthrift couple. And so that's fun at first.|||让我感到自我意识过剩的事情，然后我看到别人身上也有，就会觉得：呃，光是我自己这样就够受的了，家里绝不能出现第二个复制品。所以，你知道，起初找到一个没有你所厌恶的那个问题的人，是一件非常有趣和兴奋的事。我们也发现，吝啬鬼和挥霍者其实并不喜欢自己成为吝啬鬼或挥霍者。他们内心充满纠结。这就是为什么我们将中间的人称为“无纠结者”。因此，他们配对的几率往往比你预期的要高，比“吝啬鬼配吝啬鬼”或“挥霍者配挥霍者”的组合要多得多。所以，一开始这很有趣。
That's great. But as often happens with these fatal attractions, things get serious. You have to spend a lot of time with this person and make a lot of big decisions and, you know, about where to move and how many kids to try for and that kind of thing. We are very consistent with past research in finding that the more different they are over time, the more and more they fight over money and wish they married someone else or just stayed single. I don't think that has to be the case with all mismatched couples. There are ways to, I think, manage those discussions and manage how money flows in the household. But on average, the mismatched partners seem to have a pretty rocky go of it.
That's great. But as often happens with these fatal attractions, things get serious. You have to spend a lot of time with this person and make a lot of big decisions and, you5 know, about where to move and how many kids to try for and that kind of thing. We are very consistent with past research in finding that the more different they are over time, the more and more they fight over money and wish they married someone else or just stayed single. I don't that have to be the case with all mismatched couples. There are ways to, I think, manage those discussions and manage how money flows in the household. But on average, the mismatched partners seem to have a pretty rocky go of it.|||这很棒。但正如这种致命吸引力通常的结局一样，事情变得严肃起来。你必须和这个人共度大量时间，并做出许多重大决定，比如搬到哪里去、要生几个孩子之类的事情。我们的发现与过去的研究高度一致：随着时间的推移，两人的差异越大，他们为钱争吵得就越多，并越发希望当初嫁（娶）的是别人，或者干脆单身算了。我认为并非所有性格不匹配的夫妻都注定如此。通过一些方法，我认为可以管理这些讨论，并管理家庭资金的流向。但总体而言，性格不匹配的伴侣在生活中往往会经历一段相当坎坷的旅程。
So how does some of those interventions work if you're in one of these, mismatched relationships, can you fix it? I think it's good to have discussions and realize, maybe even both take the scale, the tightwad Spentthrift scale and figure out where we are and realize that it's not that I'm, you know, if it's a Spentriff talking to a tight one partner, you know, just realize it's not that I don't care about our future together. It's, you know, that I'm blowing household money and I do care about our future. It's just I have this quirk and, you know, let's try to find a way to work through it,
So how does some of those interventions work if you're in one of these, mismatched relationships, can you fix it? I think it's good to have discussions and realize, maybe even both take the scale, the tightwad Spentthrift scale and figure out where we are and realize that it's not that I'm, you know, if it's a Spentriff talking to a tight one partner, you know, just realize it's not that I don't care about our future together. It's, you know, that I'm blowing household money and I do care about our future. It's just I have this quirk and, you know, let's try to find a way to work through it,|||那么，如果你正处于这种不匹配的关系中，这些干预措施是如何起作用的？能修复吗？我认为进行沟通交流是个好主意，甚至双方都可以做一下“吝啬鬼-挥霍者量表”测试，弄清楚彼此所处的位置，并意识到——如果是挥霍者在和吝啬鬼伴侣交谈——这并不是说我不关心我们的共同未来。你知道的，虽然我在挥霍家里的钱，但我确实在乎我们的未来。这只是我个人的一个小怪癖，让我们试着找出一个解决它的办法。
perhaps with our account structure like joint versus separate accounts. How obvious do we want our spending to be to each other? Do we both have to know everything right away? Or can we have some private fun accounts? And, you know, working with a financial counselor and or a financial therapist, I think can be a good thing. Certainly financial therapy is becoming a more popular practice. But, yeah, it can really be. misinterpreted. You know, if I'm a spendthrift and my partner is a tight one and they get me a
perhaps with our account structure like joint versus separate accounts. How obvious do we want our spending to be to each other? Do we both have to know everything right away? Or can we have some private fun accounts? And, you know, working with a financial counselor and or a financial therapist, I think can be a good thing. Certainly financial therapy is becoming a more popular practice. But, yeah, it can really be. misinterpreted. You know, if I'm a spendthrift and my partner is a tight one and they get me a|||比如通过我们的账户结构来调整，像共同账户与独立账户的选择。我们希望彼此的消费对对方有多大程度的透明度？难道我们俩必须立刻知道每一笔开销吗？还是我们可以拥有一些私人的“快乐账户”？而且，与财务顾问或财务治疗师合作，我认为也是一件好事。当然，财务治疗正变得越来越受欢迎的实践。但是，是的，它确实很容易被误解。你知道，如果我是一个挥霍者，而我的伴侣是一个吝啬鬼，如果他们送了我一个
really terrible gift, what, you don't love me? No, it's not that. You just are really reluctant to spend money. But, you know, maybe my love language is gifts, but you can't spend the money. And so it can be real confusing. But if I just know that, well, it's not a love issue. It's just how you use money, then there's more understanding there. So yeah, just opening up the discussion, understanding these tendencies and finding money flows and discussion tendencies that work for you as a couple. But it sounds like sharing financial information is kind of important here. Even if it's not everything, right? I mean, you should share enough.
really terrible gift, what, you don't love me? No, it's not that. You just are really reluctant to spend money. But, you know, maybe my love language is gifts, but you can't spend the money. And so it can be real confusing. But if I just know that, well, it's not a love issue. It's just how you use money, then there's more understanding there. So yeah, just opening up the discussion, understanding these tendencies and finding money flows and discussion tendencies that work for you as a couple. But it sounds like sharing financial information is kind of important here. Even if it's not everything, right? I mean, you should share enough.|||非常糟糕的礼物，我会想：“怎么？你不爱我了吗？”不，不是这样的。只是你真的很不舍得花钱。但是，你知道，也许我的爱的语言（love language）是礼物，但你却舍不得花钱。因此，这可能会非常令人困惑。但如果我明白，这并不是一个关于爱的问题，而只是你使用金钱的方式，那么彼此之间就会有更多的理解。所以，是的，敞开讨论，理解这些倾向，并找到适合你们夫妻的资金流动方式和沟通习惯。但听起来，分享财务信息在这里似乎挺重要的。即使不是全部，对吧？我的意思是，你们应该分享足够的信息。
Enough, yes. I'm all about openness, but I don't know about kind of 100% immediate and active disclosure of all purchases. I think you can't keep some things to yourself. And yeah, so a lot of people, for example, have this idea that, you know, the latte factor, like, oh, if you don't buy the latte at work, then you can save up enough money to buy a home and be fabulously rich and all that. Some people really believe that. And so if they do, maybe I don't want to tell them about the lattes I'm buying because it's just going to cause a fight. And the lattes really don't matter that much in the grand scheme of things. So, yeah, it's openness good.
Enough, yes. I'm all about openness, but I don't know about kind of 100% immediate and active disclosure of all purchases. I think you can't keep some things to yourself. And yeah, so a lot of people, for example, have this idea that, you know, the latte factor, like, oh, if you don't buy the latte at work, then you can save up enough money to buy a home and be fabulously rich and all that. Some people really believe that. And so if they do, maybe I don't want to tell them about the lattes I'm buying because it's just going to cause a fight. And the lattes really don't matter that much in the grand scheme of things. So, yeah, it's openness good.|||足够，是的。我完全赞成公开，但我不知道是否需要做到 100% 立即且主动地披露所有购买行为。我认为你还是得把一些事情藏在心里。是的，举个例子，很多人都有这种想法，比如“拿铁因子”（latte factor）——哦，如果你上班时不买拿铁咖啡，你就能攒够买房子的钱，变得极其富有，诸如此类。有些人真的对此深信不疑。如果他们这样想，也许我并不想告诉他们我买拿铁的事，因为这只会引发争吵。而在宏观大局中，拿铁其实根本无足轻重。所以，是的，公开是好的，
but maybe there's room for discretion. So you can hide the lattes, but it's a little harder to hide that red corvette. Indeed. So let's talk about gift giving for a minute, since that's a topic that's on listeners' minds right now. And one perhaps surprising finding of yours is that spendthrifts seem to be at a disadvantage when it comes to giving gifts to their loved ones. Why is that? Yeah, I think it's somewhat counterintuitive because you would think that
but maybe there's room for discretion. So you can hide the lattes, but it's a little harder to hide that red corvette. Indeed. So let's talk about gift giving for a minute, since that's a topic that's on listeners' minds right now. And one perhaps surprising finding of yours is that spendthrifts seem to be at a disadvantage when it comes to giving gifts to their loved ones. Why is that? Yeah, I think it's somewhat counterintuitive because you would think that|||但或许也有保留隐私的空间。所以你可以隐藏拿铁咖啡，但要藏起那辆红色的克尔维特跑车就难得多。确实如此。那我们花一分钟聊聊送礼吧，因为这是听众现在最关心的话题。您发现的一个或许令人惊讶的结论是：在给所爱之人送礼时，挥霍者似乎处于劣势。为什么会这样？是的，我觉得这有点反直觉，因为你可能会认为
they would be best positioned to give the best gifts. They're just willing to spend. But the issue is, how do they signal that this is something different or special that I'm doing for you? If I live with a spendthrift and I see them kind of splurging all day, every day, and then they splurge on me for a gift, like, it's not anything special that they've done. This is just your normal thing. So it becomes hard to kind of signal through normal kind of consumerist, you know, capitalist means that I really do love you. And so I think for the spendthrift, you've got to do something different.
they would be best positioned to give the best gifts. They're just willing to spend. But the issue is, how do they signal that this is something different or special that I'm doing for you? If I live with a spendthrift and I see them kind of splurging all day, every day, and then they splurge on me for a gift, like, it's not anything special that they've done. This is just your normal thing. So it becomes hard to kind of signal through normal kind of consumerist, you know, capitalist means that I really do love you. And so I think for the spendthrift, you've got to do something different.|||他们最适合送出最好的礼物。他们只是愿意花钱。但问题是，他们如何向对方表明：这是我为你做的与众不同的或特别的事情？如果我和一个挥霍者生活在一起，我看到他们整天、每天都在大手大脚地花钱，然后他们为我买了一份奢侈的礼物——这并没有什么特别的，因为这只是他们的常态。因此，很难通过通常的消费主义、资本主义手段来传达“我是真的很爱你”这一信息。所以我觉得对于挥霍者来说，你必须做点不一样的事。
You've got to, maybe it's an experience that you kind of carefully plan. Maybe it's something you make. But if it's just something else you pick up in your daily kind of splurging, that's no good. it has to be a change of pace. Well, let's talk about holiday shopping more generally. Is there any research on why Black Friday and other door buster type sales are so irresistible to people? And do people feel less financial pain or emotional pain if they feel that they're getting a deal? Sure, the framing of price.
You've got to, maybe it's an experience that you kind of carefully plan. Maybe it's something you make. But if it's just something else you pick up in your daily kind of splurging, that's no good. it has to be a change of pace. Well, let's talk about holiday shopping more generally. Is there any research on why Black Friday and other door buster type sales are so irresistible to people? And do people feel less financial pain or emotional pain if they feel that they're getting a deal? Sure, the framing of price.|||你必须——也许是一次你精心策划的体验。也许是你自己亲手制作的东西。但如果它只是你在日常大手大脚花钱时顺便买下的东西，那就没用了。它必须是一种生活节奏的变化。好吧，让我们更广泛地谈谈节日购物。有没有关于为什么黑色星期五和其他“开门红”大促销对人们如此具有诱惑力的研究？如果人们觉得自己捡到了便宜，他们感受到的财务痛苦或情感痛苦会减少吗？当然，价格的框架效应。
This is a low price relative to something. What it normally is or what it should be. I mean, that does help reduce the pain of spending. Scarcity is a big driver of behavior and desire. We want scarce things. You see that with young children, too, just making something appear scarce, and they just crave it. So we want to get those scarce deals. I do think part of it is just misinformation and not understanding the kind of universe of deals that are out there day to day.
This is a low price relative to something. What it normally is or what it should be. I mean, that does help reduce the pain of spending. Scarcity is a big driver of behavior and desire. We want scarce things. You see that with young children, too, just making something appear scarce, and they just crave it. So we want to get those scarce deals. I do think part of it is just misinformation and not understanding the kind of universe of deals that are out there day to day.|||相对于某种参照物来说，这是一个低价。与它平时的价格或它本应有的价格相比。我的意思是，这确实有助于减少花钱的痛苦。稀缺性是行为和欲望的巨大驱动力。我们都想要稀缺的东西。你在小孩子身上也能看到这一点，只要让某样东西看起来很稀缺，他们就会极度渴望。因此，我们想要买到那些稀缺的折扣商品。我确实认为，部分原因只是信息不对称，人们不了解日常生活中其实到处都有各种优惠。
There are some unique deals that you can get on something like Black Friday, but there are some good deals out there on other Fridays and just in general. So we don't need like a stampede there. It's just historically we know that this has been the case. I think the landscape is very different now. So I think it's just a lack of shopping expertise or information. I would also add that it's just something to do. You know, a lot of people are off work. A lot of people are with their family, and if you've just kind of gone through Thanksgiving with them, you might need some air, so to speak.
There are some unique deals that you can get on something like Black Friday, but there are some good deals out there on other Fridays and just in general. So we don't need like a stampede there. It's just historically we know that this has been the case. I think the landscape is very different now. So I think it's just a lack of shopping expertise or information. I would also add that it's just something to do. You know, a lot of people are off work. A lot of people are with their family, and if you've just kind of gone through Thanksgiving with them, you might need some air, so to speak.|||有些独特的优惠确实只能在黑色星期五这样的日子里买到，但在其他周五以及平时，也有很多不错的优惠。所以我们其实没必要去那里蜂拥抢购。只是从历史上看，我们习惯了这种情况。我认为现在的消费环境已经大不相同了。所以我认为这只是缺乏购物专业知识或信息。我还要补充一点，这其实只是找点事做。你知道，很多人都放假了。很多人都在陪家人，如果你刚和他们一起过完感恩节，你可能需要透透气，这么说吧。
So it's a way to kind of step away from too much family time, I would say. A little goes a long way sometimes. Well, that kind of raises a question then about online shopping. You seem to be intimating that there are bargains out there every day. So do people behave differently when they shop online versus when they shop in person? or are the same psychological factors in play? Well, certainly, yeah, many of the same ones are in play, but online shopping, it's just kind of adding fuel to the fire.
So it's a way to kind of step away from too much family time, I would say. A little goes a long way sometimes. Well, that kind of raises a question then about online shopping. You seem to be intimating that there are bargains out there every day. So do people behave different when they shop online versus when they shop in person? or are the same psychological factors in play? Well, certainly, yeah, many of the same ones are in play, but online shopping, it's just kind of adding fuel to the fire.|||所以我想说，这是一种暂时逃离过多家庭聚居时间的方式。有时候，适度的小离别能起很大作用。这就引发了关于网购的问题。您刚才似乎在暗示，每天到处都有便宜可占。那么，人们在网购和实体店购物时的行为会有所不同吗？还是说起作用的心理因素是相同的？嗯，当然，是的，许多相同的心理因素依然在起作用，但网购简直就是火上浇油。
It's just it can be so effortless to pay. And especially if you have all your information saved already, you know, just kind of a couple clicks and you're out of there. You don't even know what happened. It's just like you get carried away. So, you know, if you want to control that, you've got to put up speed bumps. to erase your information, you know, don't have it, save it, log out, do like the Amazon,
It's just it can be so effortless to pay. And especially if you have all your information saved already, you know, just kind of a couple clicks and you're out of there. You don't even know what happened. It's just like you get carried away. So, you know, if you want to control that, you've/ou've got to put up speed bumps. to erase your information, you know, don't have it, save it, log out, do like the Amazon,|||付款可以变得如此毫不费力。尤其是如果你已经保存了所有信息，你知道，只需点几下，你就能完成交易。你甚至不知道发生了什么。就像你被冲昏了头脑一样。所以，你知道，如果你想控制这种行为，你必须设置“减速带”。清除你的信息，不要保存它，退出登录，就像亚马逊那样，
you know, save for later or put it in my like list instead of buy now. You know, try to enforce some kind of waiting period. Whereas in the store, you have to like get in the car, you have to wait in line. Like there are all these opportunities to second guess it. But with a lot of online or mobile shopping, it's just so seamless. But, you know, the retailers, the in-person retail, are catching up. There are these Amazon Go stores where you just kind of swipe your phone when you walk in and then you just pick up whatever you want and you just walk out. There's no checkout.
you know, save for later or put it in my like list instead of buy now. You know, try to enforce some kind of waiting period. Whereas in the store, you have to like get in the car, you have to wait in line. Like there are all these opportunities to second guess it. But with a lot of online or mobile shopping, it's just so seamless. But, you know, the retailers, the in-person retail, are catching up. There are these Amazon Go stores where you just kind of swipe your phone when you walk in and then you just pick up whatever you want and you just walk out. There's no checkout.|||你知道，点击“稍后保存”或者把它放入收藏夹，而不是点击“立即购买”。你知道，试着强制实行某种等待期。而在实体店里，你必须上车，你必须排队。有所有这些机会让你重新考虑。但对于许多网络或移动购物来说，这一切都太无缝衔接了。但是，你知道，实体零售商正在迎头赶上。现在有了这种 Amazon Go 实体店，你进去时刷一下手机，然后拿起任何你想要的东西直接走人就行了。根本没有结账环节。
Yeah, that's a scary idea. Yeah. So, you know, retailers are really skilled kind of distracting you from the moment of payment. Well, here in Ann Arbor, we have Vaughn Marr. It's like the Nordstrom of the Midwest. And their sales associates are very nice, very chatty. And before I go to the register, I have to think, well, what am I doing this weekend? Because I know they're going to ask. I can't just say something lame, like, well, whatever my wife kind of thought of. I have to have a story. And, you know, by the time I'm done, I have these bags, I don't even remember paying for it. It's just like, what happened? So they're good at kind of taking your attention away from pulling out the wallet and how much you actually spent. And then there are little tricks like you walk into Target and they've got these
Yeah, that's a scary idea. Yeah. So, you know, retailers are really skilled kind of distracting you from the moment of payment. Well, here in Ann Arbor, we have Vaughn Marr. It's like the Nordstrom of the Midwest. And their sales associates are very nice, very chatty. And before I go to the register, I have to think, well, what am I doing this weekend? Because I know they're going to ask. I can't just say something lame, like, well, whatever my wife kind of thought of. I have to have a story. And, you know, by the time I'm done, I have these bags, I don't even remember paying for it. It's just like, what happened? So they're good at kind of taking your attention away from pulling out the wallet and how much you actually spent. And then there are little tricks like you walk into Target and they've got these|||是的，这真是个可怕的想法。对。所以，你知道，零售商非常擅长转移你对付款那一刻的注意力。在安娜堡这里，我们有 Vaughn Marr。它就像中西部的 Nordstrom 百货。他们的销售人员非常友好、健谈。在我去收银台之前，我必须先想好：我这周末要做什么？因为我知道他们会问。我不能随口说一些无聊的话，比如“我老婆想干嘛就干嘛”。我必须得编个故事。你知道的，等我买完离开时，我提着这些袋子，甚至都不记得自己是怎么付钱的。就好像：刚才发生什么了？所以他们很擅长把你的注意力从掏钱包和实际花了多少钱这件事上引开。然后还有一些小把戏，比如你走进塔吉特（Target），他们会有这些
little displays of sort of junky stuff. They prime you, right? So, oh, I'll just pick up one or two of these things. And then pretty soon you're in the back of the store and your card is full. Well, the target people, they're artists. I mean, they, yeah, that's all about shopping momentum. You want to get something in the cart. You want to get that wallet opened right away.
little displays of sort of junky stuff. They prime you, right? So, oh, I'll just pick up one or two of these things. And then pretty soon you're in the back of the store and your card is full. Well, the target people, they're artists. I mean, they, yeah, that's all about shopping momentum. You want to get something in the cart. You want to get that wallet opened right away.|||摆放着各种小杂货的展台。他们先对你进行“启动效应”（prime you），对吧？所以你会想：“哦，我随便拿一两样这东西吧。”很快，当你走到店面后方时，你的购物车已经装满了。塔吉特的人简直是艺术家。我的意思是，他们——是的，这一切都是为了制造购物动量。你想让购物车里装点东西。你想让顾客立刻把钱包打开。
And then people just get into kind of just a different mode, a different mindset. So yeah, you've got to break the seal as soon as they walk in. And then they've got those big baskets, right? which, you know, oh, I'll get this comforter because there's plenty of room in here. The baskets are very accommodating, yes. I've never had one with a squeaky wheel either. It's just smooth sailing. So let's talk about gifts again for a minute.
And then people just get into kind of just a different mode, a different mindset. So yeah, you've got to break the seal as soon as they walk in. And then they've got those big baskets, right? which, you know, oh, I'll get this comforter because there's plenty of room in here. The baskets are very accommodating, yes. I've never had one with a squeaky wheel either. It's just smooth sailing. So let's talk about gifts again for a minute.|||然后人们就会进入一种不同的模式、一种不同的心态。所以，是的，顾客一进来，你必须得打破他们的心理防线。然后他们有那些大提篮，对吧？你会想：“哦，我要买下这条被子，因为这里面空间还很大。”这些篮子非常能装，是的。我也从来没遇到过哪个篮子的轮子会发出吱吱声。一切都是那么顺畅。那我们再花一分钟聊聊礼物。
Is buying a gift the same as buying something for yourself in terms of the emotions that you experience? And are you more or less likely to experience the pain of paying when you're buying somebody a gift? All the evidence we have does suggest that it's less painful. to buy the gift, but there are other emotions that could be in play, like anxiety. Will they like it? What will they think? It could be a much more stressful experience. It's just more charged.
Is buying a gift the same as buying something for yourself in terms of the emotions that you experience? And are you more or less likely to experience the pain of paying when you're buying somebody a gift? All the evidence we have does suggest that it's less painful. to buy the gift, but there are other emotions that could be in play, like anxiety. Will they like it? What will they think? It could be a much more stressful experience. It's just more charged.|||从你体验到的情绪来看，买礼物和给自己买东西是一样的吗？当你给别人买礼物时，你经历付款痛苦的可能性是更大还是更小？我们所有的证据确实都表明，买礼物时的痛苦感较小，但其中也可能会涉及其他情绪，比如焦虑：他们会喜欢吗？他们会怎么想？这可能是一个压力大得多的体验。它的情绪负荷要重得多。
There's anxiety, but there's joy. And we do find that tightwads look less like tightwads when they're buying gifts. What we were saying earlier about the spendthrift buying gifts, I think the tightwads are in a real nice position. Like if they're normally buying cheap things and then you buy something really fancy for me, I'm like, oh my gosh, I know this was hard for you. Or, you know, given how you normally spend, this was a big change for you. That's amazing. I'm actually not sure that's true because if the tightwads don't experience pain when they're buying the gift, then they're kind of getting too much credit there.
There's anxiety, but there's joy. And we do find that tightwads look less like tightwads when they're buying gifts. What we were saying earlier about the spendthrift buying gifts, I think the tightwads are in a real nice position. Like if they're normally buying cheap things and then you buy something really fancy for me, I'm like, oh my gosh, I know this was hard for you. Or, you know, given how you normally spend, this was a big change for you. That's amazing. I'm actually not sure that's true because if the tightwads don't experience pain when they're buying the gift, then they're kind of getting too much credit there.|||这里有焦虑，但也有喜悦。我们确实发现，吝啬鬼在买礼物时看起来不那么像吝啬鬼了。正如我们之前讨论挥霍者买礼物时所说的那样，我认为吝啬鬼处于一个非常有利的地位。比如，如果他们平时买的东西都很便宜，然后你给我买了一件非常昂贵的东西，我会想：“哦天哪，我知道这对你来说太不容易了。”或者，“鉴于你平时的花钱习惯，这可是个巨大的改变。太了不起了。”我其实不太确定这是否属实，因为如果吝啬鬼在买礼物时没有感到痛苦，那么他们似乎就得到了过多的赞誉。
So I think they're in a nice position as gift givers because they've set the expectations. But yeah, it's just a very different process, much more kind of emotionally charged. What about everyday purchases such as groceries or gas or necessities for tightwads? and spendthrift is the emotional experience of making everyday purchase the same as when they buy something frivolous or unusual. Yeah. So for things that are routine or necessary, the pain does seem to be muted or less influential because these things are just kind of expected purchases.
So I think they're in a nice position as gift givers because they've set the expectations. But yeah, it's just a very different process, much more kind of emotionally charged. What about everyday purchases such as groceries or gas or necessities for tightwads? and spendthrift is the emotional experience of making everyday purchase the same as when they buy something frivolous or unusual. Yeah. So for things that are routine or necessary, the pain does seem to be muted or less influential because these things are just kind of expected purchases.|||所以我认为作为送礼者，他们处于一个很好的位置，因为他们已经设定了预期。但是，是的，这确实是一个非常不同的过程，充满了更多情感色彩。那么对于日常采购，比如杂货、汽油或生活必需品，吝啬鬼和挥霍者在进行日常购买时的情感体验，和他们购买轻浮或不寻常的东西时是一样的吗？是的。所以对于那些常规的或必需的物品，付款的痛苦似乎被减弱了或者影响较小，因为这些东西本来就是预料之中的消费。
You really do see the biggest differences between the two types on things that are optional, things that make you think, like, do I need this? How long will I like it? So I wouldn't expect big differences in what they're spending on gas or milk or, you know, commodity kind of stuff. But really, it's things that seem optional. But of course, marketers are very skilled at framing optional things as necessities or investments. You know, this is not a pleasurable massage. This is an investment to kind of help your back feel better and you'll be a better parent and a better athlete or employee or whatever.
You really do see the biggest differences between the two types on things that are optional, things that make you think, like, do I need this? How long will I like it? So I wouldn't expect big differences in what they're spending on gas or milk or, you6 know, commodity kind of stuff. But really, it's things that seem optional. But of course, marketers are very skilled at framing optional things as necessities or investments. You know, this is not a pleasurable massage. This is an investment to kind of help your back feel better and you'll be a better parent and a better athlete or employee or whatever.|||这两种人在可选性物品上的差异确实最为明显，也就是那些会让你思考的东西，比如：“我需要这个吗？我会喜欢多久？”因此，我不认为他们在汽油、牛奶或诸如此类的日用品上的支出会有很大差异。但真正的差异体现在那些看似可选的物品上。当然，营销人员非常擅长将可选物品包装成必需品或投资品。你知道：这不是一次享受型的按摩。这是一项投资，可以帮助你的背部感觉更好，让你成为更好的父母、更好的运动员、更好的员工或诸如此类的人。
And that kind of framing, that can really work on tight. once. If it's, oh, well, okay, I didn't think of it like that. But spendthrifts, they don't need that. They're very skilled at viewing everything as an investment, even if it's just an investment and like, oh, I'll have a cool story to tell. That's one thing we are good at. We're good at thinking of reasons for purchasing. So the idea of retail therapy gets a bad rap, people using shopping to act as a pick me up or to make themselves feel better after a breakup or a bad day. But you've done some research that found that at least for some people, there is some truth to the idea of retail therapy, that there's a benefit. Can you talk about that?
And that kind of framing, that can really work on tight. once. If it's, oh, well, okay, I didn't think of it like that. But spendthrifts, they don't need that. They're very skilled at viewing everything as an investment, even if it's just an investment and like, oh, I'll have a cool story to tell. That's one thing we are good at. We're good at thinking of reasons for purchasing. So the idea of retail therapy gets a bad rap, people using shopping to act as a pick me up or to make themselves feel better after a breakup or a bad day. But you've done some research that found that at least for some people, there is some truth to the idea of retail therapy, that there's a benefit. Can you talk about that?|||这种包装方式对吝啬鬼非常奏效。如果是这样的话，他们会想：“哦，好吧，我之前没这么想过。”但对于挥霍者来说，他们不需要这个。他们非常擅长将任何事情都视为投资，哪怕这只是一种投资，比如“哦，我能有一个很酷的故事可以讲了”。这是我们擅长的事情之一。我们擅长为购买行为寻找理由。因此，“零售疗法”这个概念名声不太好，人们用购物来振奋精神，或者在分手或倒霉的一天后让自己感觉好一些。但你做过一些研究，发现至少对某些人来说，“零售疗法”这个概念确实有其道理，它是有益处的。你能谈谈这个吗？
I've heard all the bad things about retail therapy and how it's foolish and a big waste and it doesn't work. And, you know, as a spendthor, two studies, emotions and financial decision making, that just did not sound right to me. It seemed inconsistent with what we know about emotional experience. And in particular, the experience of sadness. So there's a lot of work suggesting that sadness is associated with thoughts of, I'm not in control of my own destiny. I am at the mercy of kind of external forces, the environment, random kind of chance. There's also other work suggesting that making choices, especially kind of pleasurable choices, can increase your sense of control, the sense that you are the captain of your own. destiny. I want this, not that. I'm in charge. And so we thought that when people are sad,
I've heard all the bad things about retail therapy and how it's foolish and a big waste and it doesn't work. And, you know, as a spendthor, two studies, emotions and financial decision making, that just did not sound right to me. It seemed inconsistent with what we know about emotional experience. And in particular, the experience of sadness. So there's a lot of work suggesting that sadness is associated with thoughts of, I'm not in control of my own destiny. I am at the mercy of kind of external forces, the environment, random kind of chance. There's also other work suggesting that making choices, especially kind of pleasurable choices, can increase your sense of control, the sense that you are the captain of your own. destiny. I want this, not that. I'm in charge. And so we thought that when people are sad,|||我听过所有关于零售疗法的负面评价，比如它是愚蠢的、巨大的浪费，而且根本不管用。而且，你知道，作为一个研究情绪和财务决策的挥霍者，这听起来太不对劲了。这似乎与我们对情绪体验的了解不符。特别是悲伤的体验。有很多研究表明，悲伤与以下想法有关：“我无法掌控自己的命运。我受制于外部力量、环境和随机的机遇。”还有其他研究表明，做出选择——尤其是令人愉悦的选择——可以增强你的掌控感，让你觉得自己是自己命运的船长。我想要这个，而不是那个。我说了算。所以我们认为，当人们感到悲伤时，
that the experience of saying, yes, this, know that, I'm making choices, that could kind of stop those thoughts of, I'm not in control, I'm at the mercy of the environment. And we thought we could interrupt that pattern of bad thoughts and bad feelings by having people make those choices. And so that's what we did. We did experiments where we made people sad. We had them watch kind of terribly sad film clips. And then we would have them do kind of shopping choices, or we would still expose them the products,
that the experience of saying, yes, this, know that, I'm making choices, that could kind of those thoughts of, I'm not in control, I'm at the mercy of the environment. And we thought we could interrupt that pattern of bad thoughts and bad feelings by having people make those choices. And so that- what we did. We did experiments where we made people sad. We had them watch kind of terribly sad film clips. And then we would have them do kind of shopping choices, or we would still expose them the products,|||经历“是的，选这个，不要那个，我在做选择”的过程，可以在一定程度上打破“我无法掌控、任由环境摆布”的想法。我们认为，通过让人们做出这些选择，我们可以打断这种糟糕想法和糟糕感受的模式。这就是我们所做的。我们做了实验，让人感到悲伤。我们让他们观看极其悲伤的电影片段。然后让他们进行购物选择，或者我们仍然向他们展示产品，
but they wouldn't get to make a choice, just like brows. I think browsing is also underrated, but it's not choosing. And so the choosers showed that they got over their sadness faster than the non-chusers, that by exercising this control over something, they were able to kind of get over it more quickly. And it really does seem to be about the choosing. It doesn't seem to be about I get to acquire some thing. Even when it's hypothetical choices, they still got over their sadness more quickly. I should say it doesn't work for anger.
but they wouldn't get to make a choice, just like brows. I think browsing is also underrated, but it's not choosing. And so the choosers showed that they got over their sadness faster than the non-chusers, that by exercising this control over something, they were able to kind of get over it more quickly. And it really does seem to be about the choosing. It doesn't seem to be about I get to acquire some thing. Even when it's hypothetical choices, they still got over their sadness more quickly. I should say it doesn't work for anger.|||但他们不被允许做选择，只能浏览。我认为浏览也被低估了，但浏览毕竟不是选择。结果表明，做出选择的人比没有做选择的人更快地走出了悲伤。通过对某事行使这种控制权，他们能够更快地摆脱悲伤。这似乎真的关乎“选择”。它似乎并不在于“我得到了一件东西”。即使是假设性的选择，他们也更快地走出了悲伤。我必须说明，这不适用于愤怒。
We didn't find it works for anger. Anger tends to be about other people. I'm mad at you. You've wronged me. I can't. I'm not sure I can shop that away. if my boss is being mean to me. Right, right.
We didn't find it works for anger. Anger tends to be about other people. I'm mad at you. You've wronged me. I can't. I'm not sure I can shop that away. if my boss is being mean to me. Right, right.|||我们发现它对愤怒不管用。愤怒通常与他人有关。我对你很生气。你亏待了我。我做不到。我不确定如果我的老板对我不好，我能否通过购物把这种愤怒买走。对，对。
I'm not going to buy a pair of shoes and feel better. Yeah. I mean, yeah, you might like the shoes, but I think you're still going to have that anger. But, yeah, sadness, that does seem to be affected, helped by making these choices. Of course, disclaimer. Is this a long-term solution?
I'm not going to buy a pair of shoes and feel better. Yeah. I mean, yeah, you might like the shoes, but I think you're still going to have that anger. But, yeah, sadness, that does seem to be affected, helped by making these choices. Of course, disclaimer. Is this a long-term solution?|||我不会买双鞋然后就感觉好多了。是的。我的意思是，是的，你可能会喜欢这双鞋，但我认为你心里的怒火依然存在。不过，是的，对于悲伤来说，通过做出这些选择确实会受到影响并得到缓解。当然，这里要声明一下。这是一个长期的解决方案吗？
Is this something you should do at every kind of pang of sadness? I'm not so sure. And I don't think it needs to be, you know, an expensive thing. found that, again, even for hypothetical choices. So, you know, give yourself a budget for this kind of thing. This is a small budget. This is, you know, like a nice restaurant meal should be like the max, I think, that we're dealing with. Because, you know, if you keep doing this and you get in debts, and then that itself will make you sad, and we don't want that. But I think used judiciously, shopping can be a nice remedy for sadness. Well, so what's next? What's next?
Is this something you should do at every kind of pang of sadness? I'm not so sure. And I don't think it needs to be, you know, an expensive thing. found that, again, even for hypothetical choices. So, you know, give yourself a budget for this kind of thing. This is a small budget. This is, you know, like a nice restaurant meal should be like the max, I think, that we're dealing with. Because, you know, if you keep doing this and you get in debts, and then that itself will make you sad, and we don't want that. But I think used judiciously, shopping can be a nice remedy for sadness. Well, so what's next? What's next?|||这是你在每次感到悲伤时都应该做的事情吗？我不太确定。而且我认为这不需要是很昂贵的东西。我们再次发现，即使是对于假设的选择也是如此。所以，你知道，为此类事情给自己设定一个预算。这是一个小预算。这就像一顿丰盛的餐厅大餐应该是我们处理的上限，我认为。因为，你知道，如果你一直这样做并陷入债务，那本身就会让你难过，而我们不希望看到这种情况。但我认为，如果明智地使用，购物可以成为治愈悲伤的良药。好了，那么接下来呢？接下来
on your research agenda, what questions are you trying to answer now? Looking into more deeply this idea of what is best for marriage, joint or separate accounts, and for different kind of couples, including couples that make very different income. You know, how do you manage those income differences? There was a lot of old work suggesting that joint accounts are good for couples. But that older work could not rule out the possibility that, well, maybe it's just happier couples that chose the joint accounts. Like we're, we really love each other, we're in it for the long haul, let's merge everything.
on your research agenda, what questions are you trying to answer now? Looking into more deeply this idea of what is best for marriage, joint or separate accounts, and for different kind of couples, including couples that make very different income. You know, how do you manage those income differences? There was a lot of old work suggesting that joint accounts are good for couples. But that older work could not rule out the possibility that, well, maybe it's just happier couples that chose the joint accounts. Like we're, we really love each other, we're in it for the long haul, let's merge everything.|||在你的研究议程中，你现在正试图回答什么问题？深入研究关于婚姻中最好的财务管理方式——共同账户还是独立账户——对于不同类型的夫妻而言是怎样的，包括那些收入差距很大的夫妻。你知道，如何管理这些收入差距？过去有很多研究表明，共同账户对夫妻有好处。但这些旧的研究无法排除这样一种可能性：也许只是更幸福的夫妻才选择了共同账户。比如“我们真的很爱对方，我们要厮守终生，让我们把一切都合并吧”。
So what we did and what we're kind of writing up now, we did this field experiment with engaged in newlywed couples who had separate accounts. And we randomly assigned them to kind of keep it separate or make a joint account and just use that or do whatever you want. And we followed them for two years. and what we found was that the couples that we kind of forced to do the joint account, they were happiest two years later. They were most seeing eye to eye on financial matters two years later.
So what we did and what we're kind of writing up now, we did this field experiment with engaged in newlywed couples who had separate accounts. And we randomly assigned them to kind of keep it separate or make a joint account and just use that or do whatever you want. And we followed them for two years. and what we found was that the couples that we kind of forced to do the joint account, they were happiest two years later. They were most seeing eye to eye on financial matters two years later.|||所以我们所做的、以及我们现在正在撰写的研究是：我们对那些拥有独立账户的已订婚和新婚夫妇进行了一项现场实验。我们随机分配他们保持独立账户，或者开设一个共同账户并仅使用该账户，或者随心所欲。我们对他们进行了为期两年的跟踪调查。我们发现，那些被我们“强行”要求使用共同账户的夫妻，在两年后是最幸福的。两年后，他们在财务问题上看法最为一致。
And so this is at least among couples who were open to our experiment. They were at least, I think, toying with the idea of maybe should we go joint and we just going to force them to do it, just do it. And it helped. I don't think every couple should go joint. there are some bad couples out there where things are kind of, you know, shaky, right? Sure. So maybe best to kind of, you know, keep one foot out the door, so to speak.
And so this is at least among couples who were open to our experiment. They were at least, I think, toying with the idea of maybe should we go joint and we just going to force them to do it, just do it. And it helped. I don't think every couple should go joint. there are some bad couples out there where things are kind of, you know, shaky, right? Sure. So maybe best to kind of, you know, keep one foot out the door, so to speak.|||因此，这至少在那些对我们的实验持开放态度的夫妻中是这样的。他们至少在考虑“也许我们应该用共同账户”这个主意，而我们只是强迫他们去做了，直接去做了。这确实有帮助。我不认为每对夫妻都应该使用共同账户。有些夫妻关系不佳，事情有点，你知道的，摇摇欲坠，对吧？当然。所以也许最好还是留一手，这么说吧。
But yeah, so we're looking into some other situations in which joint accounts might help. We're looking more into things like the post-brokness stress disorder that's been discussed, kind of how those formative experiences of financial strife early in life can stick with you and what can be done to kind of get people to understand. understand, like, oh, I do have money now. I do have money to spend. Things are okay. I can kind of shake those feelings of anxiety. Yeah. And of course, a lot of work on parents and kids still to be done. Well, Dr. Rick, this has been really, really fascinating. I hope people have gotten some good information regarding how they're managing their finances. And again, this has been really
But yeah, so we're looking into some other situations in which joint accounts might help. We're looking more into things like the post-brokness stress disorder that's been discussed, kind of how those formative experiences of financial strife early in life can stick with you and what can be done to kind of get people to understand. understand, like, oh, I do have money now. I do have money to spend. Things are okay. I can kind of shake those feelings of anxiety. Yeah. And of course, a lot of work on parents and kids still to be done. Well, Dr. Rick, this has been really, really fascinating. I hope people have gotten some good information regarding how they're managing their finances. And again, this has been really|||但是，是的，我们正在研究共同账户可能有所帮助的其他情况。我们正在深入研究前面讨论过的“创伤后穷困应激障碍”之类的事情，即早年生活中财务困境的那些塑造性经历是如何挥之不去的，以及可以采取什么措施让人理解：哦，我现在确实有钱了。我确实有钱可以花。情况已经好转了。我可以摆脱那些焦虑感。是的。当然，关于父母和孩子的研究还有很多要做。好的，里克博士，这次访谈真的非常非常引人入胜。希望大家能从中获得一些关于如何管理财务的好信息。再次感谢，这真的是
interesting. I appreciate you taking the time today. Thank you so much. If you'd like to find out where you fall on the tightwad spend-through scale, you can find a link in the show notes on our website at www.combeatingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes there, or go to Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiom. Thank you for listening.
很有意思。我很感谢你今天抽出时间。非常感谢。如果您想知道自己在守财奴与挥霍者量表中处于什么位置，可以在我们网站 www.combatingofpsychology.org 的节目说明中找到链接。您还可以在那里找到以前的节目，或者前往 Apple、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology，连写，at APA.org。《心理学热线》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的音响剪辑师是 Chris Condiom。谢谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。